>> A WOMAN WHO ACCUSE JUSTICE
BRETT KAVANAUGH OF RAPE HAS
ADMITTED SHE MADE IT ALL UP.
WHEN INVESTIGATORS CONFRONT THE
LEFT-WING ACTIVIST JUDY MUNRO,
SHE MADE IT WAS ALL A PLOY TO
STOP THE NOMINATION.
IT NEARLY RUINED A MAN AND HIS
FAMILY.
WHICH IS EASY TO DO WHEN ONE
ENTIRE PARTY REJECTS DUE
PROCESS WE NEED IS A POSTCARD
TO DIANNE FEINSTEIN.
IT'S EASIER THAN REGISTERING TO
VOTE.
CHUCK GRASSLEY IS REFERRED THIS
CREEP FOR A CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION AS WELL AS JULIE
SWETNICK AND MICHAEL AVENATTI
FOR MAKING FALSE CLAIMS TO RISK
IS TO SUPPORT ALL THIS PEOPLE
GET WHAT IS COMING TO THEM.
AFTER DUE PROCESS OF COURSE.
WHAT THEY DID TO JUDGE
KAVANAUGH THEY COULD DO TO.
HOW THE ALLEGATION WAS AND THE
THREAT IS NOT GETTING NOW IT
RAISES ANOTHER KEY QUESTION.
IF THE DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY
BELIEVE IN THE CHARGES, WHY ARE
THEY NOT -- ARE THEY PURSUING
THEM NOW?
WHY STOP JUSTICE?
WHY ARE THEY PRESENTING
EVIDENCE AND WERE WITNESSES?
COULD IT BE THE NEW THE CHARGES
WERE FALSE FROM THE START?